febrero es sinónimo de carnaval en
América Latina la historia cuenta que la
región adoptó esta festividad en el
siglo XVI de la mano de los
colonizadores españoles y portugueses
desde entonces ha ido migrando hacia la
cultura local de cada país en una
combinación de religión leyendas y
celebraciones prehispánicas Eso sí si
algo tienen en común los carnavales son
los colores las carrozas los bailes
populares y la fiesta el ejemplo más
paradigmático es el de Río de Janeiro en
Brasil
declaró abierto el carnaval de la
Democracia el carnaval de Río de Janeiro
con la cesión simbólica de las llaves de
la ciudad al rey momo empiezan cinco
días de samba y extravagantes vestidos
un carnaval de recaudaciones millonarias
que atrae a turistas de todo el mundo
por su parte la costa caribeña de
Colombia también deslumbra este febrero
con su carnaval de Barranquilla que
mezcla tradiciones indígenas africanas y
europeas el carnaval del Barranquilla es
la fiesta cultural más importante por su
diversidad por la inclusión por la
variedad producto de la combinación de
triernias que se da un carisma religioso
tiene el célebre carnaval de oruro en
Bolivia con la peregrinación a la
patrona del folklore nacional en el
centro de las festividades
venimos todos a bailar para llegar a los
pies de nuestra órbita del socavón y
pedirle favores darle gracias por
algunas cosas que nos da en la vida
bailamos por devoción otros países
latinoamericanos también deslumbran con
sus mejores colores en carnaval en los
últimos años incorporando
reivindicaciones sociales y políticas a
la tradición